how are you DJ I'm doing great rich
what's going on before we get to the
game and you're covering this weekend
last night's game what do you think that
what did the scouting community how do
you think they took in the Raiders
performance last night oh I thought
you're gonna go straight to Mullins but
you went you hit me on the Raider no I'm
gonna get to the part about how you and
everybody else missed on Mullins it's
okay no I just can't wait to see Mullins
playing NFL team then we're gonna see
how good you look
no III was I was really not for him I
went back and looked at my notes I had
at the preseason and I went bad to go
back and look at my notes to get ready
for that team and I had written none of
my notes Austin Davis 2.0 so I thought
he'd be Austin Davis I'm around the NFL
for a long time this kid so far what a
heck of a start for him happy for him
but man that's uh that was a lifeless
bunch on the on the other side for sure
do you think they quit on the on that
game last night Daniel I don't know
that's a tough word I know what the key
word means but it's a strong strong word
I'm always hesitant to go there I just
don't think they're very good so in lieu
of saying they quit I don't I don't
think they have a lot of talent right
now why are they not so very good Daniel
why well I mean you can look at the line
of scrimmage you got you can generate no
pass rush I mean the run defense was
atrocious last night and it was just
they were huge lanes they were running
through and then on the offensive side
of the ball they can't protect I think
you can make a case that cars lost some
confidence and I don't know if you know
if that's that's all on him if it's on
the lack of protection if it's not the
lack of weapons you know you could you
could attribute it in a lot of different
areas but he does not look like a
confident quarterback so they've got
they've got a myriad of issues what do
you think Gruden's plan is here you see
why don't you don't all your draft picks
you got a whole ton of them well I mean
I mean they'll be there'll be the team
of the spring I mean we'll be talking
about them all spring about what they're
going to do with these picks and I don't
know I mean I don't know if that was a
if trading if trading Amari Cooper can
that be that like insurance policy
basically just ensuring they're gonna
get the number one pick was that the
last
see to what did that happens after
watching them last night and look at
their schedule I think some we tweeted
out less I think six of their deep
remaining teams are over 500 I mean
they're gonna have the first pitch well
I mean the Giants don't look too good
either so I mean you know they don't let
me take a look at it right here so
Oakland's remaining Oakland's remaining
games there are no byes left is there
they've already had their bye coming off
of that loss in London they're all there
you're gonna be visiting them next week
the Chargers are at the black hole then
they're at Arizona at Baltimore home for
Kansas City there's a Sunday night
football home game against Pittsburgh
that's absolutely gonna get flexed out
of that's the noise you hear right now
Oakland's at Cincinnati then oh I'm
sorry I don't mean to laugh the Monday
night finale of ESPN season is Denver at
Oakland and then Oakland's at Kansas
City that's their remaining schedule
right there yeah I just feel like the
Giants are more likely to stumble into a
win or two so then that means Nick Bose
is a Raider right that would be the very
early yeah I mean you're talking about
pass rush and Gruden's talk nothing
about needing a passer arch ever since
he traded away Kalu Matt yeah well you
will see that we'll see what they decide
on the quarterback position to you know
do you think they really Wow
so what is your Daniel Jeremiah here on
the Rich Eisen show what is your
evaluation of Derek Carr right now well
he's not right
I mean he's not right right now so you
got to decide whether or not you feel
like that's because of him or what
surrounding him but I just know when you
have when you have the collective
failure they're having offensively that
nothing's off the board so when I watch
him you know I just don't see a guy
who's comfortable and confident and
pulling the trigger back there I mean I
think you somebody tweeted out a little
shot chart they're not they're not
trying to push the ball down the field
at all so even if your demons are not
successful you've got to try and you
gotta stress the field a little bit they
just have been able to do that with his
contract would you would you trade for
him would you would you pound a table in
a in a in a meeting room in a front
office in the NFL to say like just say
if you're Jacksonville let's go get him
right now let's let's flip him account
let's slip him a draft choice whatever
it would be because you wouldn't
to be very high of a draft choice with
that contract what would you would you
pound the table for him I wouldn't I
know I'm sure a lot of people would I
just you know sometimes you get in
trouble when you get beholdin to your
college grade but you know I've always
thought that Derrick was it was a good
player I've never thought of him as an
elite player now he's had elite moments
but I don't I never put him in that
class coming out and and I don't know
that I would make that investment right
now
Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show let's turn to the Chargers in the
name of bow so do we see Joey when do we
see her I don't think I see him this
week I mean I Oakland that could
potentially happen there you know one
thing to keep an eye on when you have
the foot injuries and I'm not a doctor
but having your first game back on on
turf maybe that's not maybe that's
something you want to avoid get on the
grass and that would be Oakland the
following week which graph so baseball
season is over correct yes it is yeah I
don't know in some ways it has been a
little bit of a blessing for the charges
because they've they've rolled a lot of
guys through on their defensive line and
really have a nicer rotation going right
now so when he does get back oh that's
gonna be a pretty good group they've got
now yeah I know and five and two they're
poised unfortunately for them they got a
team that's way ahead of them in
Division that's already beaten them but
how good can this Chargers team be do
you think Daniel well I think when you
look at going into the postseason first
of all you just got to find a way to get
in so you know it's gonna be a challenge
to win that division but get in any way
you can and then when you get into the
postseason I've always believed that it
comes down to strong quarterback playing
can you rush the passer if you get those
two things going you can win the whole
thing and I think this charges group if
they get expect to go with Ingram and
liege it and all that crew and and you
get rivers to continue playing like he
is I mean a bit dangerous team and and
Seattle I'm sure you've watched a lot of
film on bottom where where did this team
come from and can you say that the
offensive line problems there are fixed
can you say that
they're playing they're playing well and
they're doing some really good things I
know shot hammer got lambasted when he
got that job and everybody are
and he's old-school and this is the new
way of football now and he's he's not up
with the times and then here they are
running out there what several times you
see six offensive linemen out there with
tied in you've got Fluker in the run
game Swezey in the run game they're both
doing a really good job inside of moving
people and then that Russell's not
having to throw the ball more 30 times
so he's been very efficient he's
protected football and they found a
little bit of a formula and while the
names are all gone on defense they are
they are flying around rich it looks
like kind of that young group that they
had back at today where they were the
Legion of boom and that whole crew one
thing you noticed about Pete Carroll's
team they flew to the football and
that's what this groups doing bring me
up to speed on the kid we talked about
non-stop in the talent evaluation
portion together this year in Shakima
Griffin how is he looking so fell he did
well early in the season but now they've
got healthy you know when you get KJ
right back to go along with Bobby Wagner
those are the guys so you know it's just
still is gonna go down as an all-time
story and I think he will settle in and
be a long time starter in the NFL he
won't just be a role player he'll be a
long time starter just not yet is what
you're saying yeah I think that's I
think that his his best football ahead
of him I think he was raw and I think
just when you look at kind of the
seasoning they have there with those
other two he's not going to be at the
forefront of that defense any times you
know a few more minutes left with Daniel
Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen show
best team you've seen so far the ramps
would you want to watch yeah I've seen
I've seen the Rams and the Chiefs in
person I would say the Rams is probably
popular as the is the most balanced team
that can play any style can win any type
of way now Kansas City defense is
playing better of late than when I saw
them early but man that the Chiefs
offense still I would say their offense
would scare you even more than the Rams
but the Rams have long ways to get it
done ask the poll question of Daniel
Jeremiah who stands in the crossroads of
college and professional football Chris
all right DJ which game will be the most
competitive this weekend Alabama Alabama
Allen LLC okay you're out on that Penn
State Michigan Georgia Kentucky Rams
Saints Packers Patriots oh I love all
those games
you know I think I think that I think
Rich's the alma mater that could be a
good it's gonna be a good game I think I
think Penn State will lose I think
Michigan will win I think Penn State
will hang with him why do you think that
I think he'll be a good physical game
you know in and McSorely is just he's
he's dynamite whatever whatever term you
want to use gamer gritty you know all
those all those fun terms he's a really
good football player and I think he
finds a way to keep them in that game
for a while core Michigan just wins the
game at the line of scrimmage
so you think Rams Saints pay Patriots
Packers won't be as competitive is that
one huh I think I you know one thing
about in the Saints fans I didn't he's
one of those things where you don't
realize it I get hit on Twitter as I'm
saying you just picked against the
Saints like five weeks in a row
and has not worked out well for me okay
but for some reason I just I have a hard
time seeing them especially without
Davenport I thought that injury was huge
I don't see them slowing down this uh
this Rams off how good is Alabama terms
of college teams that you've been
looking at over the years well they've
never had an offense like this so you
know with with athletes and scheme on
defense that's a constant and then
offensively just kind of been a
rollercoaster ride I went to the game
the last time I played at LSU it was
like he was 14 nothin or something like
that it was it was a real low-scoring
game and now they have NFL receivers
tight ends and offensive linemen as
they've had at times but they've never
had a quarterback like this so yeah it's
pretty darn good how many professional
Scouts can't wait till two is eligible
right now oh yeah there's a lot of buzz
there's not a lot of buzz about this
upcoming group why Herbert's not not
buzz word no I think people like Herbert
he's raw he's raw he's not put together
yet the kid at Duke is the one that's
really interesting
no kid that's here that's the one Daniel
Jones
so why keep an eye on him he's 65 220
pounds he can really really move he's
got a live arm he's you know being
coached by Cutcliffe is not going to
hurt him any because he's going to come
in ready to play he's he's a good player
so Justin Herbert's not gonna be a top
five pick or he will just cuz no he's
gonna get him back to always go I'm
just saying in term I don't think this
group is as good as we just had so okay
so Gruden's not going to use a first
round pick on a quarterback right well
Gruden took a tackle in the top 15 that
I didn't have in my top 50 so I'm not
going to predict anything that's going
to take you came in with a blowtorch and
you're leaving with it man I love I love
it okay so let's just say two is
eligible right now is he the first
overall pick in the draft right now I
could go right now they discourage us
they discourage us from saying that I
can't don't don't look please come on
you're on this show now so so no I know
that Bay is just in generally okay it's
a safe place DJ Pongal bylaw is by far
the best quarterback in college football
that if you were an NFL team that had a
need at that position happened to find
yourself picking very high at the NFL
Draft you'd be very interesting look at
you that now you you and you are very
direct and forthright and yet infused it
with a little bit of straddling language
at the end to keep everybody happy you
were like a soup that ate like a meal
right there DJ well there's I heard
there's something coming up on Tuesday
rich I'm just trying to be long with the
times okay very good DJ you take care
have a great cast on on Sunday and we'll
chat down the line as always thanks
buddy Daniel Jeremiah the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience